The reason is sickle cell anemia is some frequent
in subsaharan Africa is because the allele makes the
person partially resistant to malaria which is endemic to
the region. Now if we move to another region
like North America, where there isn't a prevalence of
malaria, we've now changed the selection pressure and the
sickle cell allele is deleted out over over time
so that it occurs at a much lower frequency.
You recall from just a couple of exercises
back, that the homozygous sickle cell allele condition only
happens about 1 in 5000 people in North American,
in the United States, whereas roughly 1 in 50
in certain parts of sub-saharan Africa are affected
by sickle cell anemia. This has everything to do
with the heterozygote having an advantage in malaria stricken
Africa. So, obviously understanding how and why certain alleles
exist and cause traits in a population,
is a detailed venture that requires a lot
of investigation. There's actually a great website
out there to help. Its called OMIM, or
Online Mendelian Inheritance in Man. OMIM is
a database that catalogues all the known diseases
with the genetic component. And when possible, links
them to the relevant genes in the human
genome, and provides references for further research and tools
for genomic analysis of a catalogued gene. You can
see here the entry for sickle cell anemia, which
has a very large page that has a huge
description of the disease, tons of published research about
it. And even gets a detailed description of the
alleles the cause the various phenotypes. So we can
pick any disease that you know that has a genetic
component like Cystic Fibrosis. And you can search and find information about
the disease, as well as the genetic variations that are known to cause it. If
you're curious about other diseases, you should check them out in the OMIM
database. There'll be a link to it in the Instructor's notes of this page.